london had become the Litvinenko's
adopted home here they felt free they'd
fled here after alexander litvinenko
called sasha and by his wife got on the
wrong side of the Putin regime
Marine Le Pen Janka recalls what it was
like arriving in the British capital 15
years ago I was just feeling I'm safe I
was my family I was my child with my
husband but in a few days I realized I'm
in a great place and for months we felt
like a tourist you've been everywhere
the family spent six happy years in
London before the former KGB agent fell
ill and died as a result of poisoning
with radioactive polonium since then
marina Litvinenko has been determined to
clear her husband's name day in and day
out she travels to the High Court in
London to attend the inquiry designed to
find out exactly how and why Alexander
Litvinenko died people sometimes don't
understand what really happened and when
they discussed he might committed
suicide or his smuggling Roger active
material of course it makes me feel very
very sad about this for 20 years
Alexander Litvinenko worked for the
Russian military and later joined the
Russian intelligence service later he
became a critic of the regime and the
Russian President Vladimir Putin in
particular my name is Alexander tanka I
am former KGB FSB officer in London he
publicly accused Vladimir Putin of
murdering the investigative journalist
Anna Politkovskaya more people attend
celeriac aw [ __ ] you could do two
intelligence officers working for
poutine are suspected of having poisoned
Litvinenko in an upscale London hotel
bar by slipping a fatal dose of polonium
into a pod of green tea that Litvinenko
was drinking
the Russian government refuses to
extradite the two men the chief suspect
Andrey Lugovoy denies any involvement
nowadays he's a lawmaker in the Russian
parliament the Duma the Litvinenko
affair has put a serious strain on
relations between Russia and Britain the
relationship between the UK and Russia
has never satisfactorily recovered the
Litvinenko case became the murder of Eva
Nico became the sort of the image of
brutality of Putin's Russia and the
political dimension to the relationship
has not recovered and marina Litvinenko
says the climate in Russia has continued
to deteriorate in recent years a trip
back home is inconceivable she wouldn't
feel safe now we have this murder of
Boris Nemtsov in a centre of mosca it's
exactly what Sasha tried to prevent such
never been a politician himself but he
wanted Russia might be good country for
any political base for everybody's but
he believed Putin's responsibility for
what everything already happened in
Russia the public inquiry internet
Vinnie anchors death is expected to
report by the end of 2015 but what can
it achieve the pursuit of justice and
the suggestion of of the clarity of the
evidence is very important will there be
a practical ramification from this will
the killers necessarily be brought to
justice as a result of this inquiry I
think it is unlikely but it's important
for money to Litvinenko that the facts
are put on the table she wants to prove
to her Russian compatriots that
transparency is possible in a democracy
for that she's willing to relive her
trauma again and again every day in the
High Court it's not automatically never
but
means he's here and it's definitely I
feel he agreed is everything what I'm
doing bringing the truth to light is
marina Litvinenko's very personal way of
coming to terms with the murder of her
husband